salut romain a dit au pardon était tout
nu n'en sais rien je prenais un peu le
soleil en t'attendant froid a non
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
il ya des choses dans la vie qui sont
tellement évidentes qu'on finit par les
oublier
tenez moi par exemple quand j'ai testé
la cabine de cryothérapie j'ai constaté
une nouvelle fois deux phénomènes
naturels pourtant très familier un la
taille de mon pénis est directement
corrélée à la température à laquelle il
est soumis
les deux diminués en même temps c'est ce
qu'on appelle le théorème du captain
igloo 2 quand j'ai froid j'ai les tétons
qui pointent selon la loi dick deux hard
m'adore alors vous allez me dire merci
captain obvious et moi je vais vous
répondre
non vous êtes cheryl quand même non en
réalité ce que je vais vous répondre
c'est ok tout le monde sait ça mais est
ce que tout le monde sait pourquoi
et là à ce moment là vous vous allez me
répondre bon ok c'est chiant bref vous
savez pourquoi
non ça va on y va alors commençons par
le pénis et surtout mettons nous
d'accord sur les chiffres
le pénis devient petit quand il fait
froid mais c'est quoi un petit pénis au
fond est bien un pénis de taille moyenne
ces 9 cm au repos et 13 cm en érection
bon pour rester dans la bienveillance et
l'absence de jugement on va dire qu'on
peut parler de taille de pénis inférieur
à la moyenne basse quand on passe sous
la barre des 7 cm au repos et 10 cm en
érection et on parle de micropénis en
dessous de 8 cm en érection
voilà comme ça le décor est planté pour
être complet sur le sujet on peut
ajouter que la taille au repos n'a pas
de lien direct avec la taille en
érection
on pourrait aussi dire qu'on peut tout à
fait avoir une sexualité normale est
très satisfaisante pour tout le monde
avec un pénis de petite taille mais on
s'égare des parce que ce n'est pas le
sujet non aujourd'hui la question qui
nous intéresse c'est pourquoi le pénis
joue à l'escargot timide sous l'effet du
froid
et bien c'est un mécanisme de défense
non pas du pénis mais du corps tout
entier pour être précis c'est un
mécanisme de défense contre le froid qui
a vécu comme une menace par notre
organisme qui cherche à tout prix à
maintenir une température centrale
optimale pour que tout fonctionne
correctement
la température centrale c'est la
température qui règne à l'intérieur de
notre corps en temps normal elle est
comprise entre 36 degrés
et 37° sens quand notre corps se
rencontrent que la température
extérieure diminue il protège ce qu'il a
de plus précieux
ses organes vitaux est désolé de vous
l'apprendre mais le pénis n'est pas un
organe vital donc l'organisme veut
garder ses organes internes bien au
chaud et pour ça il a un truc pour
éviter la déperdition de chaleur par la
circulation sanguine
il diminue la taille des vaisseaux qui
irrigue les tissus extérieur calfeutrent
les portes de sortie en fait c'est ce
qu'on appelle la vasoconstriction
périphériques
ok vous voyez pas le rapport on va
procéder à une petite reconstitution
romain tu peux venir s'il te plaît
voici un pénis de taille normale
exposeront le à un froid intense
[Applaudissements]
ils gros lot mais c'est pas fini pendant
ce temps là dans le centre de contrôle
de la thermorégulation la température
extérieure apparaît tellement chuté le
pénis est resté enfermé à l'extérieur là
ok donc les vaisseaux qui irrigue la
peau et les extrémités rétrécissent et
comme à la différence du nez des
oreilles ou des doigts le pénis n'a pas
de structure solide
il est composé de corps spongieux et
corps caverneux et bien tout ça se
rétracte tout ça se rétracte au tu le
fais hyper bien et voilà
c'est bon pour remédier à cette
situation embarrassante il ya la
technique dite de l'élastique bien
connue des pratiquants des sports
collectifs et de leur vestiaire
complexant et impudique il s'agit de
saisir le prépuce ou la base du gland si
on le possède plus prépuce est de tirer
dessus
délicatement pour tous des plissés je
déconseille en revanche toutes les
techniques d'exposition à des sources de
chaleur pour des raisons évidentes de
sécurité
pas seulement pour des raisons de
sécurité d'ailleurs parce que si
contrairement aux organes féminins le
matériel reproducteurs de l'homme est
placé à l'extérieur du corps c'est parce
qu'il supporte mal la chaleur d'ailleurs
le slip chauffant c'est un moyen de
contraception story bon mais elle était
tombée alors eh ben on en n'est pas
vraiment sûr mais on suppose que ce qui
est en cause c'est un vieux réflexes
dont on a déjà parlé dans la vidéo 5
preuve qu'on est des animaux il s'agit
du réflexe pilot moteur qui est
responsable de la chaire de poule et qui
fait se contracter des petits muscles
chargé de faire dresser les poils sur
notre peau et bien il ya des petits
muscles du même type des muscles lisses
c'est à dire qu on les contrôle pas
volontairement dans les arrêts hall qui
entoure nos mamelons oui mamelons
battait tôt et quand ses petits muscles
se contractent l'ensemble se resserre et
se durcit ses beaux cheveux romero mans
maintenant qu'on a levé le voile sur ces
phénomène intrigant ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire
aimez vous comme vous êtes quelle que
soit la taille de votre pénis ou la
forme de vos mamelons ok c'est joli bon
on s'en fout aimez vous comme vous êtes
à très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos et
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout aux
portes et vous
[Applaudissements]